[Applause]
and voiced winner
everyone's hired because you know
there's like a full show
Carson was like and then we're gonna
know it was loaded and I was like all
right so many performances buzz for God
Oh what the Grammys or something much
like how are y'all doing timeout can you
can they hear us cuz he just asked me to
timeout oh I can can you hear now can
you hear me no y'all just let us know in
the magical box is working until then
headed to dinner
[Applause]
she is so prepared she's so gonna cook
[Music]
you guys okay cool anybody wanna go
first
yeah and please announce yourself by
your name and affiliation hey guys it's
a merge rapper inside pulse
congratulations Jake and Kelley thank
you so much Tom I want to start with you
Jake and then move to Cali what does
this win mean to you and tell me what
does Jake's would mean to you it means
the world I think I went out of breath
like I stopped my breath when they
announced my name you know
having Kelly believe me from the get-go
and be here tonight is just an
incredible thing I mean honestly that's
what like I keep making fun of the other
coasters cause home like why didn't you
turn like you miss a one chair turn like
other than the one season where Chris
blue is a 1 Charter but she was only man
that could turn formerly showing he's
literally the only person that's ever
won the voice that everybody could have
turned for and it was a win chatter I
mean it's just it's amazing it at all
it's like another extension of how cool
this show is because people that might
not get the opportunity get an
opportunity and then people that get a
slight opportunity than in a winning
like that's amazing like it's I just
think it's it's it's really cool and it
speaks it speaks of how talented he is
of how cool he is a person and I don't
know I'm just feel super blessed I
wasn't lying when I was texting I was
like man I'm super blessed like they
have just to be able to be you know
along for the ride so cuz a lot of
people think that I did a lot and I
didn't like he picked that beautiful
Christmas song we're saying yes sir I'd
never heard of it it was so beautiful
and you picked your songs and you were
like really into them so I was like yeah
anybody else I adore him he's amazing
and we've talked to him all season long
about what he's learned from you but I'm
curious what have you learned about
yourself from working with okay I mean
well he's it's it's not at least I
learned a lot about Jake each week
because like literally he would not hide
things but then all of a sudden I'd be
like wait what of the way you got that
near Arsenal like why don't we bring
that up before like he's just super
humble like I mean I grew up like you
know everybody told me my parents told
me to have a sermon
heart like that's how you should live
your life and like he is a walking
breathing servant's heart like he's such
a good dude like and on top of that like
I'm not joking like there's like a
microphone in his vocal cords cuz it's
like how you project like I have worked
on this here's just an 8 in you and it's
it's just a really cool thing to just be
reminded of how someone just genuinely
just loves music loves singing and
everything is very pure and there's no
hidden agenda and he just wants to be
here cuz he loves seeing like that's a
it's a good reminder for us all that we
know that get jaded sometimes you know
he's such a great person I know I'm not
kidding did I invent your mom with oh
and she's like shorter than me like what
happened your mom is like this is your
third wind you're catching up with Blake
congratulations
so how does that make you feel oh I mean
I literally it's the biggest joke to me
when people like congratulations me cuz
like I sat in a chair or some you know
what some I think is a cute dress and
some might not but I just I just you
know sat there and I encouraged him I'm
I am a pretty good cheerleader because I
love humans like I genuinely even the
ones that I actually don't like I really
try and find something I like like
kind of that person um I just I
literally am a glorified cheerleader you
know like I did nothing like he did
everything Bryn did everything Chevelle
did everything like god I just got to be
there and encourage them and kind of
push them in certain directions or push
them to be more than maybe they knew
they had in them but that's all you
Brooke
yep That's not me well but I I gotta say
that she she does a whole lot more than
just sit there I mean she and she's
helped me get out of my shell on stage
is really I mean and I say in every
interview like you're you're just like
the biggest cheerleader you know and and
that means more than you know then you
know so I really appreciate it I believe
in you so you are welcome hi I'm Sam
it's an Emmy a worldwide I think
something that's so beautiful about both
of you is you're both amazing parents
have you guys bonded over that at all
and through the music was there any
performance that you really were able to
relate to each other through your
children well personally I just kept I
hate to be the warning girl but I am
often in this industry when I come
across people that are either just
getting started younger than me and it's
uh it's no lie like not even just in
this industry in any industry it's hard
to be a working parent like it's hard to
fit your kids in your significant other
in like your family like it's a it's a
hard thing to do and it'll also hold
down a job that you really believe in
and your and you're into it especially
this industry it's very demanding like
so you know I've always told them like I
actually just take those like family is
first and formula get family is always
first like I think a lot of people put
all their confidence and Worth and value
in this job and it's fleeting like we
all don't we have expiration dates
everyone does and every job you know so
it's like I always really encourage them
to just do this because they really love
to because if you don't it's just a lot
of work and you're not getting to be
around your loved ones as men
he want to be you know so I'm a debbie
downer I don't mean to be but I like to
be realistic and and he loves the keys I
asked most like are you so excited about
going home and he was like I'm excited
about getting a my recliner with my
girls and I was like we're so family
I think I love a recliner it's real
uh-huh I will say there is a moment I
think when we came and visited your set
when I had asked you what it was like
being a parent and doing all this and
she told me she said you know it's it's
all about being in the moment where
you're at whether you're at work like
you're invested in your work and if
you're spending time with your family
and your kids it's all about that no
outside noise no distractions and you
know being present so there was a you
know huge piece of advice that well my
mom was a single mom you also like she
had to work so it's like I just think
that at the time that she did have she'd
try her damnedest so just be with me and
be present and I think that's important
oh we all only have so much time but as
long as that time is value like I think
it's good okay I'm also I'm Olivia Jeff
war was so delicious to see and my
question is for California I'm Kelly
since you are also a contestant winner
do you have any advice for Jake and all
oh yeah I honestly I was literally
texting it was that this morning last
night I'm not I'm just tired it was this
morning that's right that's right except
cotton news
cuz you did some amazing things awesome
but anyway I don't know I think I think
having been through it I think the best
advice is literally coming back to like
never ever ever put your worth or value
in this job and I think a lot of people
fall prey to that
and they get lost and then you know when
they're not as famous as they were they
freaked out and their identity is kind
of they're having an identity crisis and
this job is super fun like it's this
hobby is super fun and we love to be
vessels for great songs that might touch
people or move people but at the same
time we have our own lives and you've
got to invest in your family you got
invested in all that because that's
what's gonna be there in a day every day
not this job so what advice do you have
for anyone who does a competition like
this as well as a young person who kind
of didn't see themselves making it this
far
any advice oh gosh well I think you know
and I've said it multiple times and my
girlfriend's back there and she can
attest to this I went you know from the
get-go and for a little bit you know I
didn't think it was real and then every
step of the way I'm like all right honey
I'll be home next week or I'll be home
you know after battles or I'll be home
after knockouts and then in lives I was
just like all right you know and I
continue to you know doubt myself and
stuff like that and Kelly continued to
encourage me and so if I can if I can
say anything it's stop doubting yourself
get out of your comfort zone get out
there and take a chance and now tell me
what you can do Rebecca ready Access
Hollywood
first up Jake and Kelly congratulations
super question Jake how are you
celebrating and to Kelly I know in the
past you've had wagers with with Blake
about you know who've you in when you're
gonna do a few wins now that you've won
what did you get a demand of him is he
gonna call you Queen Kelly Clarkson are
you gonna make it like walking we're all
going to a dinner tonight so I'm just
gonna like walk in the room and just
smile
just like eyes anyway you know yeah it
is anything I just brought this okay I'm
just kidding
no I'm honestly where we like are
literally like brother and statistics
that we fight non-stop and argue with
each other never know when the other
ones flying anyway but it's just it's a
fun dynamic and it speaks honestly not
just our relationship of the show but
with Gwyn and with John like this has
been a really great like cast of people
to work with us you know worked with all
of them separately from this show before
this show except for Gwyn and it's just
I think that really matters you know
it's just been a really really good like
mix so what are you doing tonight
I'm gonna be celebrating with my girl
with your toddler's yeah my girls out
this this has been an incredible
experience and I will say the hardest
part is just being gone from them and so
anytime I get to spin up then tonight
she's got a good have to stay healthy
Clarkson beating Blake Shelton with a
country artist second time just honestly
I'm joking like most of it we're just
messing with each other Blake and I but
it does feel good to like turn me person
just cuz I I love artists I love music I
love all different genres of music and
like it is cool to like believe in
something you hear and turn around and
then this like change someone's life
like and I know what that feels like cuz
Mama's not a waitress anymore I was a
good one but you know I'm not interested
like and I know what it's like to go
through this process and it can be and
it can be really hard and regardless
don't just Jake but Alex Gracie all my
people like I'm I'm like you came up no
no
like email like I love keeping in
contact I love helping everyone not just
Jake which I will help obviously but I
just mean I like I think it's cool to be
supportive of everyone what jake would
you think to Kelly for making you a
better man because of the love that she
has for her children I mean Kelly I know
Kelly what is it like for you as a mom
to watch him share this moment with his
family well I think we definitely share
the fact that like it's it sucks when
you can't you love what you do but at
the same time and you can't be there and
you miss like moments especially when
they're that little their feces for how
this for like pizza it's a cool stage
like especially for little girls like
it's fun and I was asking Mason the
Commission dad is like yes but then she
like was totally distracted by the
confetti I've got a pocket full but
anyway it's just kind of it's cool to be
able to talk to someone that gets it as
well like being away from your kids and
like wanting to be there for everything
but you know we're also providers we're
parents more providers for kids too so
you're welcome
children with a better life than I have
[Music]
well a couple months back I booked us
all tickets mean Becca my girlfriend the
two girls we're going to see the
Nutcracker ballet and then after that
we're just going to you know hang out at
the house spend time with family we've
been gone for a while and so getting
back and seeing mom and dad and although
I'm one of nine so all of us try to get
together as much as we can during the
it can get a little hectic but honestly
just looking like she said her like I'm
just looking forward to getting back
watching the girls open presents have
him sit on my lap in my recliner and
just relax okay I forgot oh I'm gonna
mop meet me at Montana yellow I'm going
at we my ranch my chance there will be a
snowy Christmas my husband's birthday
was yesterday so I got into snowmobiles
kind of for me too because I want to
ride home um but we're just gonna we
love to get out in nature like we both
grew up in the found the country and
we're not really city people so it's
nice to get out and like have your kids
doing like things outside like in nature
so that's that's what we're doing the
whole time yeah if you won't find me I'm
gonna be lost on a ranch with you
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]